foreign
Francisco talk to Daniel what's up
Daniel
hey Dr John how's it going good man what
up good I'm doing great
good well thanks for taking my call
um I'll just jump right into it and I
think there might be a little bit of
crossover from uh the last caller but
interesting to get your take on on me
and my wife's situation as well cool so
we are expecting our first baby early
next year
are you excited oh yeah I'm pumped I'm
actually sitting in the nursery right
now boy girl boy dude congratulations
man
yeah so with that obviously comes lots
of new experiences uh new challenges new
choices
um and would love to get your thoughts
on a conversation that we haven't had
yet but that we know is coming and we
want to make sure we handle it well and
has to do with uh with both of our
parents um and
um you know the choice to baptize or not
in the church that we grew up in and
that our parents are still very active
in so it's a little bit of a hot button
issue but want to get your your take on
on maybe what are some of the best ways
to go about that I would say it is a hot
button issue and is not really
yeah on the surface yeah very similar to
Alaska on the surface
um
y'all have been to you and your wife
have been together you've both had your
independent experiences and for
whatever reasons you've landed where
you've landed okay we want to go to a
different church we don't want to go to
church at all we're not really want to
be making decisions for our kid this
early or we are going to do this at this
age but we're going to go to a different
building whatever whatever the reasons
are you've landed there
I think this is an incredible time
for you and your wife to spend some time
both dreaming and being very specific
about your boundaries on a host of
issues
because everybody's gonna have an
opinion when you have a baby your your
parents her parents have already
imagined what their role is going to be
they've already imagined that they're
going to be in the delivery room and
your wife's like yeah they're for sure
not they've already imagined that like
I'm gonna come over and cook dinner and
you're like no you're not you're good so
right so what are those boundaries going
to be you're going to leave your baby
you're gonna like what like that sounded
bad are you gonna like are you gonna let
uh family come over and keep your child
away I'll go to a movie or something
right let's have some of these
conversations and one of the big ones is
going to be how are we going to deal
with our
Faith Heritage and how's that going to
interact with our faith moving forward
have you all decided we're not going to
baptize our kid or we are but we're not
going to do it in this particular
building like what does that look like
for y'all
yeah I think we've kind of come to the
decision that we're not gonna do the
same Faith practice that we grew up with
and that we were married in and that you
know is what we know but we do want to
have some sort of Christian principles
and we're sort of in the middle of
exploring you know which you know
denomination Community what have you is
actually most aligned to sort of our
overall you know the way we see the
world and what we see is is you know
gonna be the best for for our family and
our community so we're still working
through that a little bit okay and and I
think mostly where the the question
comes from and you know listen to a lot
of your stuff I sort of anticipated that
might be what you say but there's been
sort of more and more as we get closer
and closer to the birth
um more sort of subtle hints and you
know little comments here and there you
know and inviting us to you know talks
at their church more than they would
have ever before
um kind of things that sort of you know
tip the Caps that like okay it's coming
they haven't flat out asked us yet or
brought anything to the head but you
know it's it's coming so I would say
absent clarity
um like without Clarity and without very
clear boundaries it feels like an
external invasion
they don't have any guidelines and so
what the only guideline they have is
this is happening
we raised you all this way y'all were
married this way you got a kid coming
and dude we're just not here like are we
missing the date or right they're making
the story about them because they have
no other information to go on
and so I this hopes isn't a
controversial statement good grief
um
I really really deeply
honor the faith traditions of
my friends and family who've gone before
me
and you have to understand that there
may be some or all depending on what
faith and what practice we're talking
about here who will see your lack your
decision to not baptize your kid in this
particular denomination
as
a move into eternity
right
like the soul of their grandchild might
be at stake here
and so I think it's fair to give people
with that type of weight permission to
grieve and be sad
because it's not just a perfunctory like
it's not just like hey we get haircuts
it's not that
it's like man you gotta do this or your
Eternal Soul is in danger
see what I'm saying like there is a
weight to that
and so I think having your
um having your beliefs and practices
awesome
be very clear and very respectful be
very direct and understand that the
blowback is bigger than somebody not
getting their way
does that make sense
it does I think one thing that we're
also just trying to be you know
conscious and aware of is you know
especially on on one side the the
familial connection to that you know
belief Heritage is is really strong so
it's certainly not only gonna you know
impact our relationship with
our parents in in a in some way but will
also probably impact the way that they
are seen amongst the rest of their
family or the rest of the way the rest
of their family sees us right so and
what you have to do is you have to let
adults be adults
and you have to make your value
judgments and you have to
control the only two things on Earth you
can control your thoughts and your
actions and here's here's what we're
gonna here's how we're gonna act is what
we're gonna do
and then as adults they get the right to
respond however they need to
and that might be them deciding well
then we're not in a relationship with
you anymore and that will be
heartbreaking and that will be ugly and
that will be messy but that's their
choice that they are making to leave you
and they're going to tell all their
friends that our kids opted out of
relationship with us
because this was the standard we set
and so all like I said in the last call
all values have consequences all of them
do
yeah right do you have any do you have
any advice for maybe how to have that
would you recommend having that
conversation earlier when we're still
sort of in the murky kind of unsure
phase or maybe trying to hold off until
we've got a little bit more clarity on
exactly where we're going what we're
doing
um I think an invitation to ambiguity
will create a mess
meaning
um if you call and ask their opinion
they're going to give it to you then
they're going to be really disheartened
when you don't listen to it
right
yeah be much better to go forward and
say here's what I think here's where we
are here's the choices that we're making
Vision work or you don't know exactly
where we're going but we know we're not
going here is that useful to have
earlier to you know let them process or
yeah I don't see any I don't know
another any other way around that is
dishonest because you're letting them
believe that
um they're just waiting at the door for
you guys and you all know now you're not
going there
and people listening will say they don't
even have it right who cares and no we
all care because we love them and we
want to be people of respect and
kindness I think you might be surprised
when they when you say hey we are
interested in trying out different Faith
communities we're going to go to a
couple others we're going to hold off on
the baptism in that whole process for a
season
um while we try to find a new home
church that's going to be for our entire
family
and we love and respect how you guys
raised us and we love that you all have
a place that you go home both in the
present and in eternity if that's what
they believe great but as for our house
we are going to run a look look out and
um we haven't abandoned our faith or
maybe you have like we're moving on from
that right now whatever the thing is to
be very very clear and don't for a
second hint that you're inviting them
into their input
right
yeah and if they're parents they're
going to give you their input let them I
don't I don't care you know what I mean
I I I don't care
and they might tell you yeah we did the
same thing when we were younger
or we wish we had asked more questions
when we were kids
or we think y'all are crazy you're
putting the soul of our grandchild at
stake we're gonna have to take some time
apart like you don't know what's gonna
happen
what I do know is this if y'all go
through with some things that you
fundamentally disagree with that you're
opposed to
and you do it to try to appease other
people
it's going to make the next Thanksgiving
really hard to be involved with together
it's going to make the next Christmas
very awkward
it's going to make the show up pop-up
visit have some extra weight to it and
now we're on the pathway to resentment
and it's not going to be their fault
it's going to be y'all didn't set up the
boundaries that you knew to be right for
y'all at the beginning
okay
okay so there is no way to do this where
it's not hard
there is no way to do this where they
don't take it as a sign that you are not
only rejecting their faith but you're
rejecting them
okay that's just gonna be part of this
conversation
and if it's what you and your wife have
agreed is best for your family and for
your new baby then hold your head up
high State your values clearly and your
intentions clearly and be respectful as
people grieve and they need some space
does that make sense I think that makes
sense it's just not an easy way around
it but the only way around the only way
on the other side of this thing is to go
right through it
yeah I'm hoping once that happens you
know they've always been respectful of
our other choices that you know first
grandchild you know it's one of those
big big oh dude yes yes egg life moments
so it's it's always heightened around it
so absolutely I appreciate your take no
you got it man and I appreciate you guys
thinking through these things and by the
way the faith issue isn't going to be
the only one
bedtimes feeding routine sleep routines
um how much how involved you are versus
how much you're at work how involved she
is is she gonna go back to work all of
those things you're going to get input
on oh my gosh you're gonna get input you
get this most stupidest advice ever
you're gonna get some great wisdom from
people
start deciding now hey what are our
values on this side of the birth and
they all change whenever the baby
actually shows up nobody's gonna keep my
kid I'm never let anyone come I don't
need a babysitter and then like three
weeks in you're like oh gosh I will hand
this kid off to the mailman if I can
just sleep for the you know for a few
hours so you'll have all these ideas
more importantly is come up with a plan
for how you and your wife are going to
stay connected and actually dig into
these issues when they come up because
it's going to show up around prom it's
going to show up around what school
they're gonna go to it's going to show
up around are we gonna let our kids have
social media or not all these things are
just part of Parenthood come up with a
with a structure a plan for not the
final answers but how are we going to
engage in these hard conversations we're
going to go on a date we're gonna go on
a retreat we're gonna go get breakfast
together we're gonna do a thing together
how are we going to continually come
back to one another and say all right we
got a new one how are we gonna figure
this thing out and that is carving a
path that your kids will walk your
grandkids will walk you're going to be
people who don't run from anxiety who
don't run from hard problems
but you join hands and you turn and face
them and you walk directly through the
middle of them and that my brothers
where healing comes from for you for
your family for our entire country
it's abandoned together and saying here
comes the storm let's walk directly into
it together